Mike Pompeo has also commented on
Israeli plans to annex the West Bank he
said the move is a decision for the new
Israeli government to make we're glad
that there's a now fully formed
government in Israel as for the
annexation in the West Bank the Israelis
will ultimately make those decisions so
that's an Israeli decision and we will
work closely with them to share with
them our views of this in a private
setting now we have three correspondents
on this story nina ibrahim is standing
by in Ramallah Harry Fawcett is in West
Jerusalem but first let's go straight to
our White House correspondent Kimberly
how could in Washington DC this isn't a
huge surprise but still it begs some
interpretation what does he mean by it's
up to Israel is this the Trump
administration green-lighting annexation
of what is internationally recognized as
illegal yeah it's really unclear but one
could only take that as sort of the
conclusion that you would get from those
statements these are the first comments
coming since the formation of the
Israeli government and the position by
this administration has always been very
pro-israel from day one whether it was
the releasing of the Mideast plan in
January which people said was decidedly
in favor of Israel the fact that in fact
none of the Palestinian leaders had even
been consulted or to the movement of the
US Embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
it's not been hard to know where the US
president stands in terms of which sides
if you want to sort of put it that way
that he's on now there's no question
that many are viewing this at as a green
light if you will to essentially annex
the West Bank by Israel the green light
by the US administration but prior to
these elections that took place in
Israel the White House had been giving
conflicting messages at one point the US
ambassador to Israel's saying that it
would be okay to move ahead with
annexation only to be sort of for the
to be a pause if you will in those
statements or a suggestion of that by
Jared Kushner the president's senior
advisor and his son-in-law saying in
fact this would have to be a joint
american-israeli decision but now it
appears we have some clarity coming from
the US Secretary of State saying that in
fact this is an Israeli decision and it
doesn't appear that he is suggesting
that there should be any positive any
sort anymore all right let's thank
Kimberly halket more to discuss on this
though we head over to Harry Fawcett in
West Jerusalem we had any reaction out
of the Israeli government of course we
should say the new Israeli government
yes not yet and I think that is key that
there is this new Israeli government as
of Monday evening the unity emergency
government as they're calling it in
which been against the former leader of
the opposition joined Benjamin Netanyahu
allowing him to stay in office he said
because of the current emergency with
coronavirus but as part of the
negotiations which led up to that
announcement he gave way on a what had
been a key issue being the annexation of
large parts of the occupied West Bank it
had been understood that he was seeking
a veto trying to ensure that other
voices were brought into the picture
before any move was made on annexation
including Israel's neighbors in the
region and also European nations but
that is not there in the deal that was
announced indeed it says from July the
first Benjamin Netanyahu can bring it
both the cabinet and to the Israeli
Parliament the Knesset and so that
combined with the fact that there is
this signal from the United States from
this very senior US government figure in
Mike Pompeo does suggest that things are
moving in that direction there is
supposed to be still this mapping plan
the the a joint team of US and Israeli
officials delineating exactly which
parts under the plan that was announced
in January
could be annexed by Israel but it seems
pretty clear that as far as Mike Pompeo
is concerned the ultimate decision will
be up to Israel alright let's cross our
thank Harry we're gonna join now on the
day Brahim
from Ramallah in the occupied West Bank
and nadare I imagine this is only going
to further cement the Palestinians
suspicions of the u.s. not really
playing that role as an honest broker
yes and they've been saying that ever
since the US administration announced
plans to move its embassy from Tel Aviv
to Jerusalem Palestinians have been
saying that the u.s. lost its
credibility as an honest broker for the
peace process they've been calling for
an international peace conference where
different parties play a role in ending
that conflict now to the issue of the
statement of Pompeo we've spoken to the
member of the executive committee of the
PLO Hanan Ashrawi she says that these
statements not only encourage Israel to
continue its actions on the ground but
gives it the cover to annex and steal
more lands we've heard also from the
Palestinian president spokesperson Nabil
aboard Ana who says that this only
empowers Israel but also that the u.s.
does not really have any legitimacy or
any ownership of the land to give Israel
the legitimacy to an exit the
Palestinian President Mahmoud Abbas have
been addressing the nation in a
televised pre-recorded televised speech
that was recorded before their Pompeo
statement but he addressed this very
issue and it's expected that his
position will remain the same the same
even after he said that he will be
cutting all signed agreements with
Israel if Israel most forward with these
plans of course this is a statement that
we've heard from Abbas many times and
many analysts would say that he really
doesn't have any more cards to play at
this point that's why he's been seeking
the international community it's been
saying that this is illegal under
international law and Israel now is more
empowered than ever by the current US
administration to continue with its
actions on the ground including
annexation which is considered illegal
under international law all right
Ibrahim from Ramallah